imaginons que l'on lâche deux pommes
dans le vide de l'espace immobiles l'une
par rapport à l'autre et espacé d'une
certaine distance qu'on notera grand
D alors les deux pommes vont s'attirer
mutuellement par leur force
gravitationnelle puisqu'ell possède une
masse petit m on supposera que les
pommes sont identiques donc elles ont la
même masse et donc elles vont finir par
se rapprocher et se rencontrer au
centre lorsque la distance qui sépare le
deux centres vaut leur largeur donc on
peut imaginer que les pommes sont
sphériques on les représente comme des
sphères on les approxime par des sphères
et donc cette largeur ce sera petitd le
diamètre d'une pomme ce qui nous
intéresse dans cette vidéo ça va être de
déterminer le temps que prennent les
deux pommes à se rencontrer donc
imaginons qu'on les lâche à un certain
instant à une certaine distance Grandé
combien de temps vont prendre les pommes
pour se rencontrer au centre et donc
pour que leurs deux centres respectifs
soient espacés d'une distance petit d le
diamètre d'une pomme alors pour faire ça
on pourrait essayer de faire le calcul
avec la relativité générale ça s'avère
en fait assez complexe et c'est vraiment
inutile dans ce genre de situation on
peut utiliser la gravitation de Newton
qui est une excellente approximation
pour toute les situations du quotidien
et en particulier pour celle-ci alors ce
que nous dit la gravitation de Newton
c'est que chaque pomme va exercer une
force sur l'autre donc disons que cette
pomme là s'appelle a et cette pomme
s'appelle B et bien la force est exercé
par a sur B qui est un vecteur donc qui
qui va attirer la pomme B vers la pomme
a cette force en intensité vaut grand G
qui est la constante de Newton fois le
produit des deux masses donc qui ici est
le même donc c'est la masse au carré
divisé par la distance qui sépare les
deux pommes qu'on nottera r au carré
alors à l'instant initial cette distance
r c'est simplement grand D mais puisque
la distance va évoluer quand les deux
pommes vont se rap approcher et bien on
peut lui donner un nom différent peti R
qui est une fonction qui va évoluer au
cours du temps alors ce qu'on peut tout
de suite faire c'est remplacer ce grand
F la force par la masse fois
l'accélération on sait avec la troisème
loi de Newton que F = ma et donc que une
force va imprimer une certaine
accélération au corps qui se déplace
avec un facteur de proportionnalité qui
est la masse et ça ça nous permet de
diviser par la masse des deux
côtés c'est ça qu'on entend lorsqu'on
dit que la la chute libre est
universelle la gravitation agit de la
même façon sur tous les corps quel que
soit leur masse donc en particulier ce M
alors ici les deux masses sont les mêmes
mais ce M c'est bien la masse de l'autre
pomme de celle qui attire et donc
l'accélération de cette pomme là ne
dépend pas de sa propre
masse alors l'accélération c'est la
dérivée seconde de la position par
rapport au temps donc imaginons qu'on
note x la position de cette pomme le
long d'un
axe et bien ça va être re x point point
les points ici dénotent une dérivée par
rapport au temps donc x point c'est la
première dérivée c'est la vitesse le
long de l'axe X et X point point c'est
la seconde dérivée par rapport au temps
c'est l'accélération c'est l'évolution
de la vitesse au cours du
temps alors bien sûr ici il faudrait
mettre un signe négatif puisque si on
s'intéresse à cette pomme là et bien par
rapport à l'axe X elle se déplace elle
va être attirée dans l'autre sens mais
si on s'intéresse à la première pomme et
bien ce sera avec un signe positif
mais en réalité ce qui nous intéresse
c'est pas vraiment la position de la
pomme mais l'évolution de la distance
qui les sépare et cette distance et bien
ça va être simplement la position de la
pomme B disons XB moins la position de
la pomme a
Xa donc on s'intéresse en fait à
l'évolution de xb- Xa et c'est ça qu'on
a défini comme étant la distance petite
R qui peut évoluer au cours du temps la
distance entre les deux pommes donc
l'évolution l'accélération de cette
distance peti r donc sa dérivée seconde
ça va être la dérivée seconde de cette
soustraction donc c'est la dérivée
seconde de XB moins la dérivée seconde
de Xa on a vu que XB point point donc
l'accélération de de la deuxième pomme
de la pomme B est négative par rapport à
l'axe X l'accélération de la pomme a est
positive elle est dans l'autre sens et
donc en fait ceci ça revient simplement
à multiplier XB par 2 puisqueon peut
remplacer x point point A par X en point
B ceci ça va nous donner deux fois cette
expression donc - 2
GM sur
r² voilà donc là on a obtenu notre
première équation c'est cette équation
là r point é= - 2 GM sur r² qu'on va
essayer de résoudre c'est une équation
différentielle c'est pas forcément
facile à voir au premier coup d'œil et
donc on va essayer de trouver une astuce
pour résoudre cette équation alors
l'astuce je vais vous la présenter puis
ensuite on va expliquer pourquoi
pourquoi ça fonctionne ça va être de
multiplier des deux côtés par 2 R point
à gauche on se retrouve avec 2 R
r ceci égale cette chose multiplié par 2
R point donc on a - 4 GM sur r² R
point alors pourquoi c'est pratique
d'avoir fait cette cette transformation
et bien tout simplement parce que de
chaque côté on va identifier la dérivée
d'une certaine grandeur ici à gauche on
identifie qu'il s'agit de la dérivée
donc par rapport au temps de la grandeur
r point au
carré pourquoi et bien quand vous avez
une fonction au carré lorsque vous la
dérivez vous obtenez deux fois la
fonction fois sa dérivée et c'est
exactement ce qu'on a ici on a deux fois
la fonction r fois sa dérivée r point
point de façon similaire à droite on
identifie la
dérivée de 4
GM sur
R alors pourquoi et bien le 4 GM c'est
une constante donc on peut le sortir on
a la dérivée de 1/ R et lorsque vous
dérivz l'inverse d'une fonction vous
obtenez -1/
R2 fois la dérivée de la fonction donc r
point et c'est exactement ce qu'on a ici
-1 sur R2 x r point fois cette
constante donc là on a simplement
réécrit cette équation sous la forme
d'une égalité entre deux dérivées et ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est supprimer
les dérivé entre guillemets c'est-à-dire
intégrer et pour faire ça il faut faire
attention on peut avoir une constante
d'intégration donc lorsqu'on intéègre à
gauche on va avoir r Point Carré plus
une certaine
constante et puis lorsqu'on intègre à
droite on va avoir 4 gm/
r plus une autre constante mais on peut
la rentrer dans cette constante là
gauche donc voilà notre première
équation on a réussi vous voyez
l'intérêt c'est qu'on a réussi à passer
d'une équation du 2è ordre avec une
dérivée seconde à une équation du
premier ordre avec uniquement une
dérivée première alors encore faut-il
déterminer cette constante grand C mais
heureusement on connaît les conditions
initiales qui vont nous donner les
conditions d'intégration et donc la
constante d'intégration la condition
initiale et bien c'est que les deux
pommes à l'instant T = 0 sont lâchées à
une distance R qui vaut grand D et puis
elles sont lâchées avec une vitesse
initiale NLE on les lâche immobilees
l'une par rapport à l'autre donc r point
vaut 0 à l'instant initial donc toutes
ces conditions là on va pouvoir les
injecter dans cette équation pour
déterminer la valeur de grand C alors
faisons ça à l'instant initial r Point
Carré ça vaut 0 ici la constante reste
la même donc on a que la constante est
égale à 4 gm/ R et ici r ça va être
grand D à l'instant initial donc la
constante vaut simplement 4 GM sur grand
D et donc si on réécrit cette équation
générale avec la valeur de cette
constante en passant la constante de
l'autre côté et bien on obtient que R
car est égal à 4 GM et je vais
factoriser 4gm facteur de 1/ r donc ça
c'est ce premier terme moins la
constante qui est en fait 4gm sur D donc
1/
d et si on veut on peut passer tout ça à
la racine carrée alors la rac carée de 4
ça va nous donner
2 et puis on a la racine carrée de G
fois tout ça la racine carrée de r Point
Carré ça nous donne r point à un signe
près ça pourrait être moins r point donc
ici on va réfléchir est-ce que R point
doit être positif ou négatif et bien ça
doit être négatif puisque les deux
pommes s'attirent donc la distance qui
les sépare diminue au cours du temps
donc finalement r point est égal à - 2 x
7 RAC
carré alors cette équation on a presque
terminé puisqu'elle nous donne
l'évolution de la distance par rapport
au temps le problème c'est qu'elle nous
donne cette évolution par rapport à la
distance elle-même donc en fait elle
nous donne la dérivée d'une fonction par
rapport à la fonction elle-même et ça
c'est un peu complexe à intégré surtout
que nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est pas
vraiment la distance mais plutôt le
temps qui s'écoule ici cette dérivée r
point c'est la dérivée de r la distance
par rapport au temps mais nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est vraiment le temps
qui s'écoule donc on aimerait plutôt
avoir DT sur Dr combien de temps
s'écoule lorsque les deux pommes se
rapprochent d'une certaine distance et
pour faire ça et bien on va simplement
inverser tout ça en inversant dr/ DT on
obtient dt/
Dr bon alors réécrivons ça lorsqu'on
inverse on obtient que DT sur Dr est
égal à l'inverse de tout ça donc c'est
égal à -
1 sur 2√
GM √ 1/ r - 1/
D là j'ai juste inversé et maintenant ce
qu'on peut faire c'est multiplier par
des r des deux côtés donc ce qui revient
en fait à prendre la
différentielle et puis
intégrer puisque on veut le temps total
qui s'écoule entre l'instant initial et
l'instant final on intègre entre
l'instant initial lorsque les deux
pommes sont espacées d'une distance
grand D jusqu'à l'instant final lorsque
les deux pommes sont séparées d'une
distance qui vaut leur diamètre petit D
et donc ici petit D et l'intégrale du
temps ça va nous donner simplement Delta
t le temps total qui s'est écoulé entre
l'instant initial et l'instant
final alors on peut tout de suite
inverser les bornes de l'intégrale pour
pouvoir supprimer ce signe
négatif ici tout ça c'est une constante
donc on peut la sortir de l'intégrale
donc je vais réécrire tout ça en sortant
la
constante et maintenant il faut
simplement calculer cette intégrale
alors l'intégrale est pas forcément très
simple à calculer on va faire un
changement de variable qui va nous
permettre de faire ce calcul vous pouvez
chercher par vous-même je vais vous
donner directement le changement de
variable pour que ce soit plus simple
donc sil faut poser en tout cas une des
possibilité pour résoudre cette
intégrale c'est de poser que R est égal
à grand D fois le sinus carré d'une
autre variable thêta pourquoi ça marche
et bien parce que le sinus carré entre 0
et 1 ça va nous donner quelque chose
d'injectif et ici on est bien entre 0 et
1 puisque petit D est positif donc on
peut faire ce changement de variable sur
tout le régime
d'intégration alors lorsqu'on pose ça on
va voir que Dr est égal à D fois la
dérivée du sinus carré donc ça donne 2
sinus thêta COS thêta d
thêta et on peut remplacer tout ça ici
directement donc on va obtenir 1/ 2
GM fois l'intégrale donc le Dr devient 2
D sinus thêta cosinus thêta d
thêta
sur en bas 1/ r ça devient 1/ d sinus
caré thêta
1/ d alors ça paraît beaucoup plus
complexe comme ça mais on va voir que ça
se simplifie grandement les bornes elles
changent puisque maintenant on intégre
par rapport à thêta donc si on prend
l'inverse réciproque de ça ça nous donne
que thêta est le
arcinus de la racine carré de r sur D et
donc quand r valit grand D r sur D ça
vaut 1 donc R1 ça vaut 1 l'arcinus de 1
ça vaut pi/ 2 donc on intègre jusqu'à
pi/
2 et lorsque r valer petit D et bien on
remplace simplement r ici par petit d
donc on a comme borne inférieure
l'arcinus de la racine de petit d sur
grand D alors faisons un peu de ménage
la constante ici 2D on peut la sortir
puisque c'est une
constante le 2 va s'annuler avec le 2
qui est
ici en bas pareil on a un facteur commun
qui est 1/ d dans la racine carrée donc
lorsqu'on le monte au numérateur ça va
donner √ d en haut et puis cette r√ d
c'est une constante donc on peut la
sortir en la multipliant par D ça donne
d à pu 3 dem maintenant on peut mettre
tout sur le même dénominateur on a 1 sur
sinus carré thêta - 1 donc ça va donner
Mo INSS sinus carré thêta 1 - sinus
carré thêta ça donne COS carré
thêta on est bien dans le premier
cadrant du cercle
trigonométrique si on trace le cercle
trigonométrique on intègre bien entre un
tout petit angle ici qui est le la borne
inférieure ce arcinus et puis pi/ 2 qui
est en haut on intègre comme ça donc le
cosinus est toujours positif donc la
racine du cosinus carré c'est le cosinus
lui-même ce qui va compenser le cosinus
qui est au
numérateur et puis ce 1 sur sinus carré
dans la racine qui est au dénominateur
on peut le monter et ça va simplement
donner un sinus carré au
numérateur donc si je réécris ça on a
l'intégrale de sinus
carré thêta d thêta et vous voyez que c
ce changement de effectivement bien
simplifier l'intégrale puisque cette
intégrale on sait la calculer assez
facilement alors pour calculer
l'intégrale d'un sinus carré une astuce
qu'il faut qu'il est intéressant de
connaître c'est que le sinus carré peut
s'écrire comme 1- cosinus de 2
thêta sur
2 alors pourquoi c'est pratique ben
souvent lorsqu'on intègre par exemple
entre 0 et pi/ 2 le COS de 2 thêta va
s'annuler puisque le cosinus va avoir
une forme un peu pe comme ça entre 0 et
et pi donc ici pi/ 2 puisqu'on a 2 thêta
et donc tout tout ce qu'on intègre en
positif ici va s'annuler avec tout ce
qu'on intègre en négatif alors dans
notre cas on intègre pas à partir de
z0ro mais on intègre à partir d'un tout
petit angle donc on va avoir une toute
petite
contribution qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
négliger ce cosinus alors je vous pouvez
faire le calcul avec cet angle
précisément mais si on fait le calcul on
se rend compte en réalité que cette
contribution est vraiment toute petite
elle est cubique et donc en particulier
si on fait le calcul avec deux pommes
qui sont espacées d'un m on obtient une
une différence de 0,1 % dans le calcul
donc c'est vraiment très faible donc ce
que je vais faire ici pour simplifier
c'est de remplacer cet arc sinus par 0
et ça marche en considérant que le
diamètre d'une pomme est très petit par
rapport à la distance qui sépare
initialement les deux pommes alors
pourquoi ça nous aide et bien si on fait
l'intégrale total entre 0 et pi/ 2 c'est
cette fois-ci le cosinus va bien
entièrement s'annuler et donc on peut le
supprimer et l'intégrale de sinus carré
correspond uniquement à l'intégrale de
1/2 ce qui veut dire que là je peux
simplement remplacer ça par
1/2 sans oublier donc qu'à partir de
maintenant il s'agit d'une
approximation et l'intégrale de 1/2i
entre 0 et pi/ 2 et bien ça donne pi/ 2/
2 donc pi/
et voilà donc la formule finale du
calcul qui nous dit quelle est la durée
après laquelle les deux pommes vont se
rencontrer à cause de notre
approximation on surestime très
légèrement de d'à peu près 0,1 %
puisqu'on néglige le diamètre des pommes
et donc en réalité ell se rencontre
légèrement avant puisquelles ont un
diamètre non nul alors on peut faire
l'application numérique imaginons que
nos deux pommes ont une masse d' peu
près 100 100
g donc si on travaille en unité de
système international c'est 10 pu-1
kg grand g la constante de Newton c'est
à peu près 7 x 10 - 11 en unité de si et
imaginons que la distance qui sépare
initialement les deux pommes c'est 1 m
donc 1 m alors si on fait l'application
numérique on va obtenir une
durée qui fait
pi x 1 sur 4 x la
racine alors g donc c'est 7 x 10 -
11 x m qui est 10 - 1 alors 10 - 11 x 10
- 1 ça fait 10 - 12 à la racine carrée
ça fait 10 - 6 et en le passant au
numérateur 10^ - 6 ça donne 10^
6 maintenant la r√ caré 7 c'est à peu
près
2,5 2,5 x 4 ça donne 10 10 et pi/ 10 ça
donne à peu près 310è donc ça donne à
peu près
1/3 et 1/3 c'est à peu près
0,3 donc on se retrouve avec 0,3 x 10^ 6
soit à peu près 3 x 10^ 5 et on
travaille en unité si donc ce sont des
secondes alors 3 x 10 pu 5 secondes
comment on peut le convertir et bien une
une grandeur qui est assez intéressante
à connaître aussi c'est la durée d'un
jour en seconde un jour c'est 8 6400
secondes donc ça c'est 24 he x 60
minutes par heure x 60 secondes par
minute et en fait ça c'est donc à peu
près 10^ 5
secondes donc là en fait 10^ 5 secondes
c'est à peu près un jour et nos deux
pommes se rencontrent donc après environ
3 jours donc pour conclure si on lâche
deux pommes immobiles dans le vide de
l'espace et qu'elles s'attirent
uniquement par leur gravité si elles
étaient au départ espacé de 1 m elles
vont se rencontrer après environ 3 jours
donc on voit que la gravité des deux
pommes est relativement faible mais elle
n'est pas négligeable non plus si on on
s'intéresse à des durées qui sont de
l'ordre de la
journée et alors pour finir si on avait
voulu obtenir uniquement cette
approximation et pas tout ce calcul
intégral précis avec le diamètre des
pommes et bien on aurait pu faire une
une petite astuce utiliser une petite
astuce qui vient des lois de Kepler en
particulier de la troisème loi de Kepler
la loi des périodes qui nous dit quelle
est la période d'une orbite dans un
système à deux corps comme celui qu'on
considère puisqu'on considère deux
pommes donc deux objets
massifs et donc ceci c'est un problème à
deux corps qu'on peut résoudre avec les
lois de Kepler alors nos deux pommes
elles ont un centre de masse qui a une
masse totale de deux fois la masse des
deux pommes et donc imaginons qu'on
lance les pommes avec une certaine
vitesse et bien chacune des deux pommes
va
Orbiter autour du centre de masse alors
l'orbite est un peu mal dessiné ici mais
il faut vraiment imaginer qu'on peut
avoir toute une variété d'orbites autour
de ce centre de masse en particulier
cette variété d'orbite et bien ce sont
les différentes excentricités on peut
avoir des orbites qui sont circulaires
autour du centre de masse on peut avoir
aussi des orbites plus étiré plus
excentrique qui forment des ellipses et
enfin des orbites extrêmement excentrées
qui forment des ellipses très allongé
qui passe tout près du centre de masse
et donc dans le cas limite d'une
excentricité infinie on obtient une
orbite où la pomme partirait en ligne
droite passerait juste à côté du centre
de masse et puis reviendrait donc la
période total de cette orbite ce serait
deux fois la durée que prend une pomme à
rejoindre l'autre pomme au centre de
masse donc en fait cette durée Delta T
et bien c'est donc environ puisqu'on
néglige encore une fois le rayon des
deux pommes la période de l'orbite ici
extrêmement allongée divisé par 2 et
cette période et bien elle est donnée
par la loi de Kepler elle vaut
précisément 2 pi x d/ 2 à la puissance 3
demi divisé par la racine carrée de G FO
la masse du centre de masse c'est-à-dire
2m 2
GM donc si on divise cette période par 2
on a un 2 en bas qui vient s'annuler
avec le 2 qui est en
haut le 2^ 3 demi au numérateur bien on
peut passer en bas ça va donner 2 au Cu
lorsqu'on le rentre dans la racine
carrée 2 au Cu x 2 ça fait 2^iss 4 et
lorsqu'on sort ça de la racine ça donne
2^iss 2 c'est-à-dire
4 et ainsi on se retrouve bien
avec pi d^ 32/ 4 GM qui est exactement
la même
formule